- En 2016, en pleine crise
avec la Russie, l'Ukraine
en e e en Chine ce train
de marchandises en contournant
le blocus russe. L'Ukraine
fait enfin partie de la route
de la soie, proclame le ministre
ukrainien.
La Chine a des relations
diplomatiques et commeleleles
avec l'Ukraine, son premier
fournisseur de maïs depuis
30 ans, et a toujours défendu
sa souveraineté.
(musique sinistre)
Ce qui ne l'a pas empêché
d'accroître ses échanges
avec la Russie avec, en 2019,
l'ouvertdududu gazoduc sibérien
sous les regards de Xi Jinping
et de Vladimir Poutine,
à qui on demande de donner
l'ordre d'ouvrir le gazoduc.
Après s'être juré une amitié
et des liens sans limites avec
Vladimir Poutine à l'occasion
des Jeux olympiq P P P Pékin,
le leader chinois marche sur
des oeufs sur la question
de l'invasion de l'Ukraine.
La Chine s'abstient, car,
ce qui lui importe avant tout,
ce sont ses propres intérêts et
ses clients des nouvelles routes
de la soie avec l'Union
eunenenene au premier plan.
Plus de 100 pays ont adhéré à
la Belt and Road Initiative,
B-R-I, ou, en français
"nouvelles routes de la soie",
un projet lancé en 2013
et cher au président Xi Jinping
et qui évoque les voyages
de Marco Polo, de la Chine
en Europe.
(cloche)
FRÉDÉRIC LASSERRE, géographe,
Université Laval
Le chemin de fer est un axe
emblématique, effectivement,
des nouvelles routes de la soie.
Développement du chemin de fer
vers l'extérieur de la Chine
qui, encore une fois,
ne ddedededede 2013; ça faisait
déjà plusieurs années que
les Chinois cherchaient à
connecter le réseau chinois
vers l'extérieur, donc
vers la Russie.
- Frédéric Lasserre est coauteur
d'un livre récent sur le sujet.
- Les Chinois, précisément,ont e
au projet de nouvelles routes
de la soie, donc entendent
développer, favoriser
le développement portu
construire de nouveaux ports,
prendre des participations
dans des ports à l'étranger.
Donc, plusieurs volets pour
favoriser aussi le développement
de ces nouvelles routes
de la soie dans le domaine
maritime, en développant
des routststststststaient,
là encore depuis longtemps.
- À l'image symbolique
de la ville de Chongqing,
la Chine veut absolument
faire croître son économie
et développer les régions
du Centre et de l'Ouest
de la Chine, comme le Xinjiangï.
Donc, importer les matières
premières et exporter
des pr a a a a a a avec
de plus en plus de valeur
ajoutée.
♪ ♪ ♪
Exporter aussi la technologie
chinoise avec des projets clés
en main, vite fait et souvent
bien fait. La Chine dame aussi
le pion au Japon en construisans
le monde.
- Il s'agit essentiellement de
fournir des occasions d'affaires
pour les entreprises chino
effectivement, dans des accords
que l'on présente comme
gagnant-gagnant avec les pays
partenaires des nouvelles routes
de la soie. Donc, ce sont des
projets visant soit à promouvoir
l'exportation ou la construction
d'infrastructures, offrant
des servpapapapapapapapays
partenaires, mais pour lesquels
des contrats seraient octroyés
à des entreprises chinoises,
donc leur donnant des débouchés
à l'exportation et des débouchés
supplémentaires.
- Mais attention, la Chinevevev,
facilement. C'est pourquoi
un pays lourdement endetté
comme l'Argentine est venu
se joindre pendant les JO
de Pékin, aux nouvelles routes
de la soie.
- Pour beaucoup d'États
de la planète qui sont
en délicatesse financière
avec les finances...
les institutions financières
internationales ou les banques
occidentales, rererererererere
un recours qui peut être
intéressant d'explorer.
- Pour construire des ports
comme celui de Colombo,
par exemple, elle prête sans
condition de rectitude politique
ni souci pour la corruption.
Mais attention : la Chine
c c c c c c c c cadeau.
Incapable de rembourser
son prêt, le Sri Lanka est
obligé de céder à la Chine
son deuxième plus grand port
pendant 99 ans.
♪ ♪ ♪
Cette splendide autoroute
au Monténégro ne va nulle part.,
engloutissant le cinquième
de la dette étrangère du pays.
Mais il en manque 130.
On appelle ça : le p
de la dette.
- Le gouvernement chinois,
apparemment, aurait donné co
consigne aux banques chinoises
d'être un peu plus sévères,
un peu plus critiques dans
l'octroi de certains prêts.Donct
une baisse des prêts accordés
par les banques dans le cadre
des projets des nouvelles routes
de la soie.
- Pour sécuriser ces routes
maritimes, la Chine contrôle
une bonne centaine de ports
dans des endroits stratégiques
comme Panama ou Djibouti, avec
une première base militaire.
En Italie et en Grèce également,
ce qui inquiète les Occidentaux,
qui pourraient croire qu'avant
même ses intérêts économiquesla.
- "Hégémonique", ça me semble
un petit peu exagéré. La Chine,
de toute façon, ne prétend pas
être la s
même à l'horizon 2050.
En tout cas, pas encore.
Elle voudrait simplement
être une superpuissance
à l'horizon 2050, si possible,
devant les États-Unis.
♪ ♪ ♪
- En attendant, la Chine
surveille la réaction du monde
à l'invasion de l'Ukraine,
tandis que l'Occident pense
aux visées de celle-cisusususuïe
comme territoire chinois
et non pays souverain.